yeah welcome to this video yeah this is
a bit different yeah we got a dual
commentary again and done yeah I've been
challenged to a to a duel here by this
guy g2g dude can yeah he's got him he's
got her own YouTube channel as well and
it will do commentary just as I'm doing
it so um I like to point out that
channel to you is pretty fresh channel
and very little views but he's taking
you Jefford in producing the video so
make sure to check him how to JD
cannabis them is the name of the cella
i'm not mistaken i'm going to put that
link into into the description of course
so we've got an enzo here and the the
tag control is 32 by the way oh yeah d 5
is normal here black also has something
like 36 and 85 I have a soft spot for
those ideas with g6 but d5 is just them
the simpler move to play gym now we can
take on d5 or Bishop b2 which will be
towards the move that is recommended in
some modern books however I don't think
that it leads to anything black it's
totally okay after taking and throwing
c5 now it takes a while with 32 you can
take some liberties with your time it's
not you're not in such a rush okay um
yeah now i have two basic ideas I can
play with see 5 or I will see six and I
can also do this starting with a 5 so
that before it's not happening normally
you want to place your 6 in this
position and only play c5 in cases where
why does playing f3
so I'm going to start with that the c6
and if he goes f3 I will play c5 to get
counter play the center no that's not
happening is playing his route to you
one hmm ok ok I'm going to develop that
night I mean 97 would obstruct the
bishop by the way don't be irritated by
the the ratings yeah it looks a bit a
bit weird then might have two thousand
six hundred something this is what ICC
has as the so-called blitz rating yeah
this is the non auto pairing you had the
challenge system where you can just
challenged people and this is a
different rating than the five minute in
the Challenger system there are ratings
of three thousand something 2600 is kind
of it's not bad but it's not like a top
rating and his rating is completely off
because he just very recently registered
on the ICC so um he's done he should be
am a bit high actually so let's see here
do I just take on you forth and [ __ ] me
the simple solution just do that if you
place night takes I have f5 right and
I'm winning a piece so let's to take
with that bishop on the other hand if I
go f5 now what is this the e1 rook is
not protected hmm
is it a 5 move I don't see why not yeah
I don't see why not let's go for that
yeah I guess he had to take with the
rukon e4 which is not the most natural
move ever but probably what he needed to
do yeah I'm not really seeing any any
particular way to to save himself I
probably check on b3 so anyway after
let's grab that piece so I'm piece up
ray the item I'm getting an eye to d5
which make things quite comfortable yes
so 95 I guess 94 I go Bishop f5 so um
he's got one pawn right just one pawn
bishop only five SM is a pretty good
piece so it's not I still have to be a
bit circumspect but it's not really a
dangerous Bishop g6 was my intention go
no nothing wrong with that so what about
maybe this and just attack that rook and
ask a skit way it wants to go does it
have any any natural squares yeah this
is not really am a natural square I'm
going to place you five now and check
your center here so stare threat i don't
i don't see it so i'm going to take on
d4 yes speed up now okay age from time
morning yeah because i'm under under one
minute and three minute to em this is
fields like pretty early warning okay h5
i can still just take so no real issue
can even go d three white forfeits
antalya yeah he lost some time um yeah
that was a pretty equal ish position up
to that point where Wendy form but we're
going to play the second game now and
Andy Chan Shia here we go I can accept
that game style now I got the white
pieces oops no not the rook food yeah
I'm going neither three and does you
form my usual kind of stuff and III
that's an interesting move order where
why does not playing um deformed it's
exactly a get against this kind of move
see takes he takes queen bee three
yeah in case if you're wondering his
over the board rating is I think roughly
about 2,000 so on it some slight
mismatch yeah but he challenged me and
down I'm up for that I will play those
some dual matches I really like to do
them I think I'm there they are good fun
and it doesn't hurt to get to to
introduce other channels and give people
choices and ideas what other channels do
and yeah maybe you can set up your own
channel it just it's just fun to do so
what happens here be 795 this is a quite
awkward situation yeah not something
that is played with much enthusiasm but
it's actually probably the best move hmm
they are probably deform it is not that
bad yeah it looks a bit strange we
should have five and then back but in
fact white has played III as well it's
not like I'm going to smash him here
quickly blackest is ok you can go e 6
and so on and while I'm of course I'm
sorry of course Tempe up it's not it's
not a huge issue really so what now just
look C 1 norm maybe we'll see one not
quite sure
if he goes 'if I've I think I can take
you five there's no real reason not to
your mind must be white must be somewhat
better because of them that is the
quicker and more active development but
really not sure that it is that much
okay night Eve for looks very very
normal very tempting after a six but
he's got five maybe rabbit that's not
really that great so let's go on a tear
for try to jump to to see five hmm I'm a
greedy person sometimes what about be
seven I might have night XD form this is
this kind of idea possible okay let's
just get that Bishop dark squared Bishop
is good good to remove from blacks camp
it is a dangerous piece sometimes on age
too so I'm glad that I could letter now
can get rid of it and I don't really see
how is not taking it wow I mean I have
not be seven at least or a form
man it's very tempting I'm not quite
sure what's better here many and many
interesting lines time morning yeah okay
I have to play right d 7 and then a four
also was interesting looks a bit sick to
take that Bishop only seven but ok after
a 4 i'm playing on the light squares and
taking the light squared Bishop is
helpful well is that such a big decision
ok I have to take and now I think maybe
this one so night before I have Bishop
you one keeping that piece I can be a
play Bishop before now or a form be
false or making quite a bit of sense ok
well I can take that pawn here right
nothing really no reason not to take it
so what I'm trying to say so I'm going
to take it and the bishop p.m. that's a
very safe now maybe this if he takes a
nightie for you see will give me that d7
Bishop so if he takes that he has to go
to some wacky square ok prevent 94 and
now that looks like very nice extra porn
and see
I cook a seven and so on that was cool
down nighty night should be five maybe
bishop yeah i was thinking i can retreat
okay I said taking be to now hmm oh I
didn't think about that so Pullman want
to go be three here let's trade one
route
might be too i can take b8 and play
rugby one that wins the night and takes
takes vs. pin on the bishop on ya it
oops no that's not working group b 1
it's time black however that dead pieces
lost him no is God rook c8 I would
looked at so I played it badly after
rook c8 it's going to be going to be a
draw whoo so bad some bad technical
player bye-bye me so now i was thinking
i mean i saw that i can play b3 and
everything but i thought that this is
better but no i didn't i didn't really
see rook c8 of course with those two
bishops being lined up on the sea farouk
c8 is going to save him ok then so that
was bad yeah let's start with that game
maybe so we had this opening with the
dream after which black quite often it's
not playing Bishop f5 but playing
something like a six or a six because he
feels that Bishop f5 is a bit premature
and what we saw that this is essentially
true because here white is a bit better
but it's not a decisive thing or
anything so all that was normal a six
and 94 an alternative was he for opening
up the position that's also interesting
because of my better development that's
um certainly and an idea but that also
looks normal yeah I cannot really go
here or let's say it doesn't really net
much was this is just not doing anything
not see five is good yeah and b5 was
really surprised me I thought he had to
take and play 94 then I'd go back and
white has a has a slide plus but that's
not
the size of by any means okay went b5
and I went 97 am unclear what's best
this was not suppose in bed as well but
I thought a I thought a B form might be
a problem with light a 5 coming and
indeed the computer gives that as equal
I still would have thought that white is
a bit better but it wasn't as good as
what I did I think and now rubed you one
yeah this was preparing Bishop II one in
our cases here and now I went a form
it's not necessary this is given by the
computer maybe I'm if you trade those
two then Bishop before it's going to
happen it's probably quite good maybe I
for was a bit too quick but he gave me
that pawn and of course I was happy to
take it I think it's really just a pawn
there is some basically no one no
particular compensation however of
course I I screwed it up badly by go
ahead Bishop f5 huh said of f3 yeah I
should have looked for that for tactics
him I was just playing that
strategically desirable move that takes
away before but it wasn't technical
technical mode let's say and here that's
a mistake yeah it's a mistake I didn't
see you see it so that was a good chance
um that he could draw that game in the
game before let's pull that up in the
game before and let me switch that so we
had an Enzo and this rook e8 Bishop f8
line that's from my book and really a
line that I like very much I think it's
a very young harmonious way for black to
set up his pieces we you get that
castling in early and have that nice
rook e8 bishop ave configuration and you
sent us flexible you can sometimes go
where c5 was d5 was 26 everything is
some is flexible and after 93 i went d5
that's the simplest way to do
and he took which is not bad as i said
this move is recommended in many am in
many year Conte books but after
capturing cancelled NC 5 black would
ultimately equalized in my opinion the
night on g3 is not a particularly great
place give a greater peace and all in
all there's just two little going on
okay took and I think all that is pretty
normal rookie 1986 Quincy to
everything's cool yeah and now I think
probably he has to play something like
let's say Bishop detour route 81 and
then you can try to play for you for the
immediate eform is not as as good right
here maybe you can take with the night I
was thinking f5 is still interesting but
Bishop g5 makes things I'm a bit tricky
I guess and now the rook is protected
only one so after let's say this this
time might be might be ideas check check
I'm not sure because of this and the
rook here not in play maybe this is ok
for wide quite often to looks would be
stronger than the queen but not sure
here yeah this is to start working rook
takes was also an option after that I'm
a bit better simply because of that I QP
and it's not a very harmonious piece set
up so black has a slight advantage but
night x was probably okay Bishop takes
f5 is just giving that giving that pawn
away let's piece away I'm sorry and yeah
he tried that but after a couple of
moves
it really turned out that there was no
one compensation at all for whitey and
this in this game yeah ok guys thanks
for watching this some do a commentary
video makes sure to watch the Jonathan's
version as well on his channel always
good to compare the two views and check
out his channel he's got some good
videos on there and he has absolutely no
views at the moment is such a new
channel ok thanks for watching and check
out his place on YouTube bye